building a snowman is light-hearted
winter family fun unless you're the
Dueck family from Manitoba Canada each
year they create some icy engineering
which is snow joke
this is rebooting the snowman on an
industrial scale we're gonna need a
bigger carrot yes this is a 20-foot
abominable snow giant 20-foot snowman
awesome how do they build this icy
edifice this giant snowman uses 2,500
cubic feet or 60 cubic meters of snow
the problem with building such a big
snowman is Noah's not a good building
material to make the snow strong enough
to hold the weight of the snowman they
first have to compact it so to build
this after do it family built the
scaffold to shape the snow they use
cardboard molds which they placed around
the scaffold and pack snow into
compressing it in the process snowflakes
are made up of lots of tiny ice crystals
with air gaps in between them so by
packing the snow together it reduces the
amount of air between the ice crystals
making it stronger also when the snow is
heated up during the day some of it will
melt and this forming water falls into
the gaps between the ice crystals where
he freezes binding the ice crystals
together much more tightly the final
result is a huge snowman it's ginormous
it's kind of scary
[Music]